matthieu delormeau vous avez un cadeau
pour moi vous savez que c'est mon
anniversaire
ce soit d'après des mois alors mathieu
pouey se passe-t-il à 20h11 ce soir
avant qu'on ait le film le film ce soir
c'est sur ces 8 1 c'est le meilleur film
qui est partout il ya que des trucs
crasse rassure les audiences tf1 sera-ce
rackham août les chaînes c'est que des
rats sera ce soir ça se passe sur ces
huit ans le reste ses frères tu te
mènera tralou star internationale qui
vient de loin qui ne parlent pas le
français mais c'est pas grave vous est
polyglotte
ça veut dire que vous parler plusieurs
langues bien que j'aurais passé j'avais
pas le citer plusieurs grottes et je
pense qu'il ya plus de personnes dont
vous êtes fan
alors évidemment si je vous demande quel
est votre sport préféré
j'aurais plus grand chose à dire non
j'aime là j'aime le foot qui aiment le
tennis c'est vrai tennis tennis tennis
non vendée le tennis
alors tu peux attaquer en tout cas doux
c'est qui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
thales a mais c'est un fait merci
à la bagarre et de l'autre grande série
mais vous savez quoi
mais pendant trois secondes les yeux
pers est fait bon bien prête à tout et
vous lui ressemblez beaucoup alors être
le sosie de rafael nadal c'est oui j'ai
déjà fait pas leur affaire et vous fait
pas dans la vie et des sosies pas le
rapport je suis chauffeur de bus à
madrid
ap ap rès pour la mairie
[Applaudissements]
c'est radio ce qui n est pas favorable
30 à 39 ans le 30 ans le même âge là et
39 à 34
bravo tu connais tous et merci et merci
quand même d'avoir été là ça me fait des
shows dans le monde entier en tant que
les ont vraiment essayé raphaël on a eu
miguel mais si titi c'est pas ça s'est
joué à ça il y avait tout le coeur de la
merci quand même comme ça déjà c'est
tout et non